y tú
en qué miedo descubriste que eres
valiente
esa pregunta me la hizo una persona que
se ha dedicado toda su vida a combatir
la violencia en contra de las mujeres
cuántas mujeres
pasan toda una vida de violencia y
después de muchos años salen y buscan un
primer empleo conocen alguna
cuanto miedo tuvo que haber y cuánto
valor se requiere en otro contexto
cuántos de ustedes les ha dado miedo
temor a emprender un negocio
cuántos de ustedes les ha dado miedo o
temor cambiarse de trabajo dejar una
pareja cambiar de vida irse a vivir a
otro país cuánto temor existe y cuánto
valor se requiere decía roosevelt tienes
que hacer exactamente eso que tú crees
que no eres capaz de hacer
déjame preguntarles algo tú hoy que
crees que no eres capaz de hacer
o en el pasado que creías que no eras
capaz de hacer y hoy haces
a futuro qué harías
supieras que no puedes fallar que serías
capaz de hacer
el día de hoy les quiero compartir dos
historias la historia de juan luís y una
historia propia comencemos con juan luís
cuando yo era director de recursos
humanos en una empresa conocí a juan
luís juan luís era un empleado que
trabajaba en un pequeño departamento de
la compañía él era gerente juanis
provenía de una familia muy humilde que
vivía a dos horas de distancia en una
casita muy pequeñita arriba de la
montaña muy cerca de morelia por dos
horas de distancia
todos los días se paraba temprano e iba
a trabajar y regresaba por las noches y
con mucho esfuerzo había logrado esa
gerencia estaba muy orgulloso de lo que
había logrado pero juanluis por alguna
razón se sentía incómodo y es algo que
yo podía notar incómodo y ese es el
primer concepto del que les quiero
hablar el día de hoy
la incomodidad les quiero contar la
historia
una langosta imaginen una langosta
gigante que está de pronto queriendo
cambiar de caparazón porque está
incómoda de acuerdo está creciendo y
cada vez que crece y crece se le va
quedando chico el caparazón entonces la
langosta va a una formación rocosa y en
esa formación rocosa suelta el caparazón
y cambia de caparazón porque ya le queda
incómodo si las langostas tuvieran
doctores o si las langostas tuvieran
alguien que le pusieron relajante
muscular un baile o algo las langostas
no crecerían de ninguna manera el
estímulo que hace que la langosta crezca
es precisamente que se siente incómoda
qué quiere decir esto
la incomodidad no es mala la incomodidad
es fabulosa siempre y cuando utilicemos
esa incomodidad para poder revolucionar
lo que estamos viviendo y reinventarnos
de acuerdo
pero hay un problema el problema es que
hay una frase que decimos que nos
sentimos así
no está tan mal
pues hay novios peores o novias peores
esposos peores esposas peores trabajos
peores jefes peores y el problema es que
nos quedamos en nuestra zona de confort
hay gente que no le queda otra opción y
que tiene que seguir esté en ese trabajo
haciendo eso que tiene porque tiene una
necesidad pero mucha gente y una gran
cantidad de personas se quedan ahí por
una decisión auto impuesta una
limitación ante impuesta por miedo
pues bien déjenme contarles ahora un
poco de mi mi primer trabajo fue de
vendedor ambulante
y cuando yo era vender ambulante yo
quería ser abogado yo decía los abogados
son gente importante gente que usa
trajecito como este
y que les va muy bien y que además
pueden ayudar a las personas
entonces pues estudié en una escuela de
derecho una escuela muy exigente en
méxico después ingresé a una firma de
abogados a la firma de dos nos gane el
mundo y dije pues bueno esto es y aquí
bueno después de algún tiempo pues sí
con algo de suerte tengo que admitirlo
me hice socio de la firma
pero me sentí incómodo quiere saber con
qué
y trabajo dentro de la firma consistía
en terminar la relación de trabajo de
las personas
yo trabajaba el primero de pasante luego
de abogado y luego de socio despidiendo
personas
y a lo largo de mi vida despedir 36 mil
y ahí perdí la cuenta
imaginen 36.000 personas
pues bien todas esas personas a las que
debes pedir todas esas pues siempre
reaccionaban de la misma manera con
cierto enojo con cierta grado de
frustración algunos llorando desde luego
pero hubo una que me marcó hasta el día
de hoy fue gustavo gustavo es una
persona que trabajaba en la industria
hulera en la zona de tultitlán muy cerca
de acá y cuando me tocó era notificarle
que la planta cerraba y que se quedaba
sin trabajo llegué y había algo en su
casa imaginen una casa en la zona de
tultitlán y había una celebración muy
grande al parecer unos 15 años
los quince años de su hija
sería tocó y quien me abre fue la hija y
la hija mis bienes de la empresa y papas
y papá te hablan de tu empresa ha de
serlo de tu aumento que esperabas
cuando les notifique a lo que venía y se
enteró por la razón por la que estaba yo
ahí
gustavo firmo
y dijo presenciado este paso de ser el
mejor día el peor día
que nunca lo vuelva a ver
fue gustavo
quien luego expresar de manera textual
lo que las otras 36.000 personas
pensaban de mí
36.000 personas que se sentían así
cuando yo hacía mi trabajo
36.000 personas son muchas personas 36
mil personas es lo que cabe en un
estadio deportivo de algún equipo
profesional pero si consideras 36.000
personas y las multiplicas por el número
de personas que dependen de estas 36 mil
personas pues el número empieza a ser
bastante más grande y ya no se trata de
cualquier estadio se trata del mismísimo
estadio azteca
imaginen a estas 36.000 personas y yo en
el centro más sus dependientes
económicos y todas gritando al mismo
tiempo ojalá que no te vuelva a ver en
mi vida
fue ahí que decidí
dejar ese caparazón que yo tenía esa
protección económica que me daba el ser
socio de la firma de abogados más grande
del mundo
y buscar otro fue ahí que decidí dejar
de destruir para empezar a construir
dejar de despedir para empezar a
contratar a promover a capacitar a
incluir ya recuperar esas 36 mil almas
que debía
evidentemente fue una decisión muy
complicada había un amigo que me decía
jorge si ya no eres feliz fíjate en que
te estás mintiendo
y después de reflexionar un tiempo me di
cuenta que efectivamente que yo me
estaba mintiendo porque yo había
escogido ser abogado para ayudar
personas y yo estaba haciendo lo opuesto
así que qué creen que hice
pues decidí
dejar de ser abogado
dejar el saco a un lado
y empezar de nuevo buscar otro caparazón
empecé en el área de recursos humanos de
una empresa buscando contratar personas
y buscando de alguna manera recuperar
esas 36.000 personas que yo le debía a
la vida
hay un diagrama que explica claramente
cómo en estos momentos de crisis o en
estos momentos en los que uno se ve
conflictuado uno puede elegir dentro de
varias opciones cuando tú eres niño y
hasta la adolescencia
realmente no tomas muchas decisiones con
relación a tu destino en la adolescencia
empiezas a definir hacia dónde te
quieres mover y en la edad madura
claramente defines tu destino o el que
tú crees que es tu destino y caminas
hacia allá con toda fuerza pero llega un
punto en el que las cosas no salen como
esperabas y te empiezas a sentir
incómodo hay gente que no le queda de
otra y tiene que permanecer ahí por
resiliencia y por necesidad pero llega
una crisis y en esa crisis tú tienes la
elección de resignarse
por miedo o reinventarte con valentía
de acuerdo
ahí es donde tú tienes que decidir si
quedarte en tu caparazón
aunque esté incómodo o cambiarte y
reescribir tu guión y este es el segundo
concepto del que les quiero hablar
reescribir tu guión
antes de ser abogado
yo intenté ser actor de teatro
y recuerdo que cuando me entregaban un
millón hay veces que me gustaba y hay
veces que no me gustaba para nada y yo
me lo aprendía y decía bueno pues es el
guión que me tocó
que me topo
cuántas veces te has sentido así en tu
vida cuántas veces haces algo que te
tocó estoy con esta pareja que me tocó
estoy en el país que me tocó estoy en el
trabajo que me tocó les tengo una
noticia no te toca
no te toca
si no te gusta el ión que te tocó o te
gustaba pero ya no
tíralo
y escribe otro
otro cuantas veces sea necesario
de acuerdo
déjenme regresar con juan luís cuando se
me acerca un día y me dice jorge quiero
intentar algo más quiero buscar algo
fuera de mexico quiero llegar a ser
director
él es tu plan juan luís mi hijo pues mi
plan es muy sencillo tiene dos pasos y
dije a ver cuáles son
el primero preguntarte qué es lo que
tengo que hacer y el segundo que me
digas y hacerlo
o que me estás poniendo mucha
responsabilidad pero déjame ver qué
puedo hacer por ti y le di tres consejos
le dije la primera cosa que te sugeriría
es no caber en dónde estás
la segunda es ya no se trata de ti se
trata de tu equipo y la tercera es no
basta saber hay que actuar de buena fe
si no no te sigue a nadie ni a la
esquina
juan luís después de pensarlo un tiempo
regresó y dijo ya sé qué voy a hacer en
ese momento vi un programa muy exigente
de liderazgo y él decidió ganar los 500
gerentes él quería ser el primer lugar
para no caber en donde estaba estudió
todas las tardes para lograrlo pero
además todos los conocimientos que
adquirían los iba aplicando en su
trabajo para agregar más valor y ya no
caber en donde estaba en su puesto en
ese momento
en el segundo punto para que ya no se
tratara sólo de él sino de su equipo
repartía los casos con todo su equipo y
se ponía a estudiar con ellos y se
preocupó porque ellos también aplicaron
los conocimientos y en el tercer punto
no solamente sabiendo más que ellos sino
actuando de buena fe hizo un compromiso
y les dijo yo no me voy a ningún lado
hasta que ustedes no estén promovidos y
se enfocó en que en que los que
crecieran fueran ellos y entendió que
cuando quieres ser líder de algo de lo
que sea a los que tienes que ayudarles a
tu equipo y ellos te van a aventar para
arriba
esto también lo hizo en su casa todas
las tardes cuando llegaba a la oficina
se sentaba con sus hijos en la cocina
limpiaba la mesa que estaba en el
comedor y entre los niños y él se
dedicaban dos horas ellos de ser tarea y
en la preparar sus casos cuando los
niños se cansaba le decían ya estoy
cansado les decía lo siento pero no nos
podemos parar todavía porque queremos
ser mucho más de lo que somos hasta
ahora habrán niños
al pase un tiempo juan luís como se lo
podrán imaginar ganó el concurso de
liderazgo
fue promovido como director de finanzas
en españa' y el día de la ceremonia de
premiación fue fueron los dos niños los
niños los saludé y le dije oye qué tal
tu papá qué orgullo sí pero hay algo que
no entiendo dónde están las copias de mi
papá
como los cuales pues lo que las que
estudiaba ya el otro ya le reclamé
eligió y papá ya que ganaste que ella no
quiere ser mucho más de lo que eres
hasta ahora
juan luís nos enseñó
y nos re inventó el concepto de equipo
nos enseñó que el primer equipo es tu
familia
juan luís fue una de esas 25.000 almas
que logrado rescatar hasta este momento
pues de todas las que de vos
el cambiar de trabajo el cambiar de
profesión el iniciar un negocio el hacer
algo que tú quieres está al alcance de
tu mano solo depende de ti el único
problema lo que te frena son tus miedos
la sociedad la cultura tu familia te va
a querer meter en un molde y es hasta
que tú te sales de ese molde que empieza
la curación pero si te vas a salir no
salgas con la actitud de pues vamos a
ver si funciona
sal con la actitud de vamos a hacer que
funcione
permite que ese miedo que sientes si el
revulsivo que te permita salir y romper
ese caparazón de una vez por todas y
empezar a escribir un nuevo guión
permite que se esa fuerza interior la
que te lleve donde quieres estar y si no
sabes en dónde quieres estar no te
preocupes
explora todo aquello que existe a tu
espíritu busca en esos sueños que tengas
de muchos días atrás y que te despiertan
en la noche pero todavía no te atreves a
hacer
acuérdate que inteligente no es la
persona que sabe exactamente a dónde
tiene que ir sino la que sabe a dónde no
debe de volver
y valiente es la persona que vence sus
miedos
así que ve
sal de aquí escribe la primera página de
tu guión
y encuentra de una vez por todas en cuál
de todos esos miedos que hoy sientes
estás dispuesto a descubrir que eres
valiente
[Aplausos]